[inaudible]
ALLEN.
I SHOULD LET AT ATKINS.
BATES.
BELL. FOR JUST.
BRADFORD [inaudible]
CABALLERO [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
DODD [inaudible]
THE RUSSELL [inaudible]
GALGIANI [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
GROVE [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
HILL [inaudible]
WITH SO -- TADO [inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible]
JONES.
LEYVA.
MCGUIRE.
MITCHELL.
MONNING [inaudible]
MORE LOCK [inaudible]
RAIL [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
PORTANTINO.
ROTH.
RUBIO.
SKINNER [inaudible]
EARN [inaudible]
STONE.
NUMBER Y. CASKEY [inaudible]
WIENER [inaudible]
WILK.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT WHAT
THE MEMBERS ON FOR IN OUR GUESTS
BEYOND THE RAIL AND IN THE
GALLERY PLEASE STAND.
AS WILL BE LEAD IN PRAYER THIS
MORNING BUYER CHAPLAIN SYSTEM
CHAU BORMAN AFTER WHICH WILL BE
LED IN THE PLEDGE.
BY SENATOR CAFIERO.
LET US REMEMBER THOSE REAR IN
GOD'S PRESENCE.
THE FOLLOWING POEM IS BY DENISE
LEVERTOV.
AS SWIMMERS DARED TO LIE FACE TO
THE SKY.
AND WATER BEARS THEM.
AS HAWKS REST UPON AIR.
AND AIR SUSTAINS THEM.
SO WHAT I'D LEARNED TO ATTAIN
FREE FALL.
AND FLOATS.
ENTER CREATORS SPIRITS DEEP
EMBRACE.
KNOWING NO EFFORT EARNS BEST ALL
SURROUNDING GRACE [inaudible]
CREATORS SPIRITS.
TEACH US TO REST IN YOUR DEEP
EMBRACE.
WITH A LIVELY CONFIDENCE IN YOUR
TENDER COMPASSIONATE GRACE A MAN.
PLEASE JOIN ME AS WE SALUTE OUR
FLAG.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG
[inaudible]
INDIVISIBLE WITH.
YEAH.
MEMBERS WERE MOVING TO
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR.
WE FIRST HAVE UP SENATOR MCGUIRE.
FROM THE MAJORITY LEADER'S DEATH
CENTER.
YOU PREPARED.
YES MISTER PRESIDENT MISTER
TERRY PLEASE ROUTE.
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION 45%
OF REQUIRE RELATIVE TO
CALIFORNIA GROWN FLOWER MONTH.
THE RIVER BAR THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER PRESIDENT I AM PLEASED TO
BE AT A PRISON S. C. R. FORTY
FIVE WHICH RECOGNIZES THE MONTH
OF JUNE TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN IS.
CALIFORNIA GROWN FLOWER MONTH
WHICH IS ON YOUR DESK I'M NOT
SURE IF YOU COULD TELL. FOR THE
PAST HALF CENTURY CALIFORNIA'S
FARMERS HAVE WORKED THE GLDEN
STATE'S FERTILE SOILS AND MADE A
SAID AMERICA'S NUMBER ONE
AGRICULTURE PRODUCER AS WELLS
EXPORTER.
AND AS MANY FARMERS LIKE TO SAY
IF IT'S FOR BREAKFAST LUNCH OR
DINNER IT WAS PROBABLY GROWN
RIGHT HERE IN THE GOLDEN STATE.
AND THE SAME CAN BE SAID FOR
CALIFORNIA'S FLOWER INDUSTRY
WHICH IS DOMINATING THE FORCE IN
FLORAL IN THE UNITED STATES.
CALIFORNIA FLOWER GROWERS
REPRESENT 75% OF ALL
DOMESTICALLY GROWN CUT FLOWERS
MEETING THE STRICTEST GROWING
STANDARDS ON THE PLAN.
HUMBOLDT COUNTY FOR EXAMPLE IS
ONE OF THE LARGEST FLOUR
PRODUCERS IN THE STATE AND IS
KNOWN FOR ITS IDEAL GROWING
CONDITIONS FOR TULIPS LILIES AND
IRISES.
AND IF YOU ARE WATCHING JEOPARDY
AND YOU HAVE A CATEGORY OF
FLOWERS ARCADE ON THE NORTH
COAST IT'S THE LARGEST REGION OF
FRESH CUT TO LOOKS IN THE U. S.
AND THE BIRTH PLACE THE BIRTH
PLACE WHICH IS MAKE SENATOR
MITCHELL VERY EXCITED OF THE
LEGENDARY.
STARGAZER LILY -- WHICH IS ONE
OF THE FLOWERS ON YOUR DESK
BEFORE YOU.
THE TOTAL ECONOMIC IMPACT OF
CALIFORNIANS GROWN FLOWER
FARMERS WHOLESALERS TO RETAIL
FLOORS IS MORE THAN TWELVE POINT
TWO BILLION DOLLARS IN.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN LAYS IN
GERMAN THE SENATE PLEASE JOIN US
IN RECOGNIZING TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN OF JUNE CALIFORNIA
GROWN FLOWER MONTHS [inaudible]
THANK YOU. SIX I THINK CENTER
MATCHES ANOTHER ITEM
[inaudible]
I'M SORRY.
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE AT ALL
BETA SISSIES MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON THE SITE
[inaudible]
ALLEN.
HI ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS.
AYE BATES AYE BILL.
I PORGES.
HI BRADFORD ART I COME A YEAR --
I CHIANG [inaudible]
I DODD.
BY THE RUSSELL [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
GLAZER.
HI GROWTH.
HI HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL.
I WITH SO -- TITLE.
HI JACKSON [inaudible]
BY JONES.
HI LEYVA.
AYE MCGUIRE [inaudible]
BY MITCHELL [inaudible]
HI MONEY.
BY MORE LOCK.
I'M REAL.
AYE NIELSEN.
AYE PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO.
HI ROSS.
BY [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
SKINNER.
I STERN.
AYE STONE [inaudible]
NUMBER.
I LIKE OWSKI HI I WIENER.
AYE WILK.
HI.
SENATE MCGUIRE MOVES A CALL --
MIX OF MEMBERS IF YOU'RE WITHOUT
OBJECTION WILL MOVE TO JOURNEY
MEMORY CENTER NELSON ARE YOU
PREPARED FOR YOUR JOURNEY MEMORY.
I'M SORRY I'M SORRY.
I'M SORRY CENTER MCGUIRE YOU
HAVE INTRODUCTIONS I'M SORRY NO
IT'S ALL GOOD MISTER
PRESENTATION SO MUCH MISTER
PRESIDENT IS HONORED TO BE ABLE
TO INTRODUCE CASEY CONGRESS HE'S
A CO AN AMBASSADOR THE
CALIFORNIA CUT FLOWER COMMISSION
WE'RE GRATEFUL FIRST PARTNERSHIP.
IN BRINGING US THE BOUNTY OF
CALIFORNIA EVERY YEAR IF YOU
COULD PLEASE GET CASE YEAR ROUND
OF APPLAUSE PLEASE.
AND IF YOU WOULDN'T MIND JOINING
THIS FOR AN OFFICIAL SENATE
PHOTOGRAPH WITH YOUR CALIFORNIA
GROWN FLOWERS.
WELCOME TO CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE.
AND WE'RE GONNA DO A GROUP PHOTO
[inaudible]
THE
MEMBERS IF THERE'S NO
OBJECTION WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO
A JOURNEY MEMORY SENATOR NELSON
ARE YOU PREPARE FOR YOUR JOURNEY
MEMORY.
SENATOR FLOOR IS YOURS.
MEMBERS.
THIS PRESIDENT LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN THE SENATE
WE ARE HERE TODAY AND I'M ASKING
THAT WE WOULD ADJOURN IN THE
MEMORY OF KAMEL SOLOMON JAKKS ON
HIS FAMILY IS IN THE BACK.
OF THE CHAMBER HERE WITH US
TODAY.
HIS DAUGHTER LINDA.
ACTUALLY CAMPAIGN FOR MANY MANY
YEARS AGO AND THEN WORK FOR ME.
THIELEN LET.
BEEN DEAD A CAREER WORKING FOR A
FEDERAL JUDGE.
BUT A WONDERFUL FAMILY.
AND A WONDERFUL LIFE STORY.
OF AN ACCOMPLISHED MAN
[inaudible]
BORDER LEBANON.
HE RECEIVED MANY SCHOLARSHIPS.
THE STUDIED MEDICINE CAN BE
UNITED STATES IN.
NINETEEN FORTY SIX MOVED TO
ALABAMA.
WHAT TO A SMALL COLLEGE THERE IN
ALABAMA [inaudible]
METIN.
MARRIED HIS WIFE MARINA.
THEY WERE MARRIED FOR FIFTY FOUR
YEARS.
HE THEN GOT A MASTER'S DEGREE
FROM VANDERBILT.
HE DISCOVERED A CERTAIN KIND OF
A ANTI OCCIDENT THAT HAD A GREAT
THERAPEUTIC VALUE.
I DON'T KNOW THAT HE MADE
MILLIONS OFF OF IT BUT IT WAS.
QUITE A DISCOVERY FOR A YOUNG
MAN.
HE HAD FELLOWSHIPS [inaudible]
FROM.
ELEVEN HE WAS A DIRECTOR.
OF CLINICAL CHEMISTRY.
AND GASSED IN.
ALABAMA.
HEAD OF CURRICULA AT THE
UNIVERSITY.
OF ALABAMA EXTENSION PROGRAM
[inaudible]
HE HAD.
TAUGHT IN PHILOSOPHY
[inaudible]
PHYSIOLOGY [inaudible]
BIOCHEMISTRY [inaudible]
THE ALABAMA.
HE WON GRANTS.
INCLUDING THE UC DAVIS SCHOOL OF
MEDICINE.
WHICH TO STAB WISH THE ACTION ON
PRESENTS.
AT THAT UNIVERSITY.
HEADS MANY PROFESSIONAL
ASSIGNMENTS THROUGH THE YEARS.
HE WAS A TENER [inaudible]
TO PROFESSOR [inaudible]
AUBURN.
RAND OFF IN MACON COLLEGE.
ASSOCIATE PROFESSOR OF MEDICINE
[inaudible]
THE ALABAMA.
IT ALSO THEN.
THE UC DAVIS [inaudible]
AT AMERITRADE [inaudible]
ASSOCIATE.
HE WAS A RESIDENT SCHOLAR
[inaudible]
THE DAVIS.
IN THE COLLEGE OF BIOSCIENCE.
HE WAS A RESEARCHER.
THEY ALSO TALK SPORTS.
IN SPORTS MEDICINE.
HAD A FIFTY YEAR ACADEMIC CAREER.
OVER FORTY PAPERS.
BUT HE PUBLISHED [inaudible]
HE HAS [inaudible] SIX CHILDREN.
WHO ARE HERE WITH US TODAY?
FOURTEEN GRAND CHILDREN.
AND TEN GREAT GRANDCHILDREN.
LET ME JUST ACKNOWLEDGE HIS
CHILDREN.
LINDA RANDY LAUREN DAWN
[inaudible]
BARBARA [inaudible]
JOSEPH.
YOUR RECORD TODAY.
THE MAN WHO CAME TO FOR THE
AMERICAN DREAM [inaudible]
AND BECAME.
THE AMERICAN DREAM [inaudible]
COBOL [inaudible]
THOMAN.
JACKSON NAY WITH GERMAN DESIGNER
TODAY LADIES AND GENTLEMEN.
THANK CENTER NO SIN OUR DEEPEST
CONDOLENCES TO THE FAMILY AND IF
YOU BRING THE NAME FOR TO BE
PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED
.
STILL UNDER PRIVILEGES OF FOR
SENATOR UMBERG ARE YOU PREPARED
FROM MAJORITY LEADER SUGGEST
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES -- WE HAVE BEFORE YOU
TODAY A SPECIAL GROUP TO BE
RECOGNIZED BY ALL OF US.
IT'S THE CAL STATE LONG BEACH
NATIONAL CHAMPIONSHIP VOLLEYBALL
TEAM AND THEIR REPRESENTATIVES --
THEY CAME OF IT LUNCH TODAY THEY
SAID THEY SPECIFICALLY ONE TO
COME TODAY BECAUSE IT'S CENTER
BILL DODDS BIRTHDAY.
THAT'S WHY THEY WANTED TO JOIN
US TODAY.
CASE YOU DIDN'T KNOW THAT YEAH
THERE WE GO.
SO I'M I AM ESPECIALLY PLEASED
BILL RECOGNIZE CAL STATE LONG
BEACH SUCH AS BECAUSE THEY'RE IN
OUR DISTRICT.
BUT BECAUSE AS I MENTIONED
THEY'RE BACK TO BACK.
NCAA MEN'S VOLLEYBALL CHAMPIONS --
THEY'VE BEEN TO THE FINAL FOUR
OF SEVERAL TIMES IN THE LAST
FOUR YEARS -- THIS YEAR ON MAY
THE FOURTH THEY DEFEATED THE
UNIVERSITY OF WHY TO BECOME THE
CHAMPS IN TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHTEEN THEY DEFEATED UCLA IN
OH BY THE WAY -- COACH ALLEN I
WAS QUITE.
HAPPY TO TELL ME ABOUT THAT IS
YOU SAY ALUMNUS -- THE TO QUOTE
COACH KNIGHT.
THEY SMASHED RECORDS RIGHT LEFT
AND CENTER BUT WHILE THEY DID IT
THEY DID IT THE RIGHT WAY THEY
DID IT.
VERY UNSELFISHLY THEY DID IT
WITH HARD WORK AND GREAT.
THEY BROUGHT ALL THEIR TEAMMATES
ALONG AND DID IT TOGETHER.
ALSO WITH US TODAY REPRESENTING
LONG BEACH VOLLEYBALL ARE A
STUDENT ATHLETE CARLOS DANIEL
REVERE VEGA.
CARLOS.
RIGHT HERE WITH THE TWO THOUSAND
AND NINETEEN TROPHY.
RIDLEY FROM FROM SAN JUAN PUERTO
RICO AND ALSO ANOTHER PLAYER --
ALEXANDER NECKLACE ON A STASI
ID'S.
HOW WAS THAT THERE CENTER BOARD
JUST A DO THAT CORRECTLY?
AS WELL AS ASSISTANT COACH NICK.
NICK MAKE GREAT -- YOU MAY KNOW
HIS FATHER -- BRUCE MCRAE.
ALSO IN THE FIA FLOODED DIRECTOR --
DIRECTOR OF COMMUNITY
GOVERNMENTAL RELATIONS RICKY
MCMANUS AND CHRISTOPHER REESE
ASSOCIATE VICE PRESIDENT LADIES
AND GENTLEMAN -- ALSO SENATOR
MORLOCK AN ALUMNUS I THINK WANTS
TO JOIN US HERE IN RECOGNIZING
THE CAL STATE LONG BEACH.
NCAA CHAMPION TIMES TOO THANK
YOU ALL.
THANK YOU SO.
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SENATE WE SAY
CONGRATULATIONS TO THE MEN'S
VOLLEYBALL.
INTO TO A CHAMPIONS
AGAIN
CONGRATULATIONS THE NC TWO EIGHT
CHAMPION FROM CAL STATE LONG
BEACH AND THE WHAT'S.
ALREADY BEEN MENTIONED LET'S
ALSO DO A SPECIAL -- SENATE
CONGRATULATIONS HAPPY BIRTHDAY
TO SENATOR DODD LET'S WISH HIM A
HAPPY BIRTHDAY.
TO COLLEGE
[inaudible]
SENATOR MITCHELL.
BOB PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR
MISTER PRESIDENT.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WILL COLLEAGUES WE'VE WE'VE
RECOGNIZE ONE SORT OF FLOUR I
WANT TO DRAW YOUR ATTENTION TO
THE GALLERY. TO EIGHT A SEA OF
ROSES IN THEIR BEAUTIFUL RED IF
THE WOMEN OF DELTA SIGMA THETA
SORORITY INCORPORATED WOULD
PLEASE STAND.
YOU ALL OF SEE THESE BEAUTIFUL
WOMEN IN THEIR THE MEN CREAM.
ALL OVER YOUR DISTRICT.
DELTA SIGMA THETA SORORITY
INCORPORATED WAS ESTABLISHED AT
HOWARD UNIVERSITY A HISTORICALLY
BLACK COLLEGE BACK.
NOW YOU KNOW MY STAFF IS ABOUT
THE GET ME BEAT DOWN IT SAYS
ESTABLISH IN TWENTY THIRTEEN
THAT IS HARDLY THE TRUTH.
WHAT YEAR WERE YOU ALL ESTABLISH
LADIES? NINE THIRTEEN THERE WE
HAVE IT AGAIN AS WE VOTE AND
KNOWLEDGE MEMBERS OF THE GREEK
LETTER ORGANIZATIONS ON THIS
FLOOR YOU KNOW THAT THEY ARE A
PROFESSIONAL WOMEN WHO CARRY A
PLATFORM.
ON THAT FOCUSES ON THE CRITICAL
NEEDS OF OUR COMMUNITY THEY'RE
ALL COLLEGE EDUCATED WOMEN AND
THEY ARE IN YOUR DISTRICTS
ACROSS THE STATE.
NOW I'M GOING TO EMBARRASS MY
COLLEAGUE FROM PASADENA.
WHO HE SAYS BUT THE PASADENA
CHAPTER HAS GIVEN HIM THE
DUBIOUS TITLE OF A MAIL?
TO WHICH I GUESS IS THE MAIL
DELTA.
I DON'T KNOW I DON'T KNOW SARS
IF THAT'S EVEN A REAL THING YOU
THEIR SICK IN THE HEAD NOW.
BUT COLLEAGUES PLEASE JOIN ME IN
WELCOMING THE FINE WOMEN OF
DELTA SIGMA THETA SORORITY
INCORPORATED TO THE RED CARPET
TODAY THIS IS WHERE THEY BELONG.
DO YOU KNOW FOR PURPOSE I RISE
ALSO TO COMMEND AND CELEBRATE
WITH THE DELTAS YESTERDAY IN MY
DISTRICT THE PASADENA CHAPTER AT
ITS WHITE LINEN AFFAIR TO
BENEFIT THE DELTA FOUNDATION AND
SO I AM PROUD TO REPRESENT.
THE PASADENA CHAPTER OF THE
DELTA IS AN WAS CELEBRATING WITH
THEM.
I HAS THE MAIL.
TO BY THE WAY THEY GET ME THAT
TITLE I DIDN'T GIVE IT TO MYSELF
SO.
WELCOME LADIES AND THANK YOU FOR
BEING THE DELTAS.
IN MEMBERS OF I GET OUT MY VOICE
I WOULD LIKE TO EXTEND A SPECIAL
RECOGNITION TO TRACE YAK INSOFAR
WAS REGIONAL DIRECTOR FROM
ARIZONA.
LENA BRIDGES THE NATIONAL SOCIAL
ACTION ENSURE -- GOLLY THE COAL
COORDINATOR OF THIS EVENT SO
WELCOME ON THE PATH OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE TO YOUR
SENATE WELCOME LADIES OF DELTA
SIGMA THETA.
MISS REQUIRE FOR PURPOSES.
OKAY YEAH WHEN OKAY.
THE OBJECT.
MEMBERS NEXT MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED
READ MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY
WILL BE DEEMED READ.
REPORTS FROM COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND A MAN I'M
AMENDMENTS ADOPTED.
MOTIONS ARETE RESOLUTION NOTICES.
THIS IS THE TIME TO REMOVE ANY
ITEM FROM CONSENT CALENDARS OR
ANY ITEMS TO BE REMOVED.
SCENE.
NINE OKAY CONSIDERATION OF THE
DAILY FILE.
SECOND READING FILE ITEMS ONE
THROUGH FOUR MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTY ONE WITH
THE MOMENTS FIVE SIXTY FIVE WITH
THE MEMONS TEN SIXTY THREE
WITHIN MINUTES AND ASSEMBLY BILL
A FIFTY ONE ALL RIGHT MEMBERS
SENATOR THIRD READ SENATE THIRD
READING HAS BEEN DISPENSED WHAT
ASSEMBLY THIRD READING ITEM.
TWENTY ONE MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
EIGHTY ONE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GIPSON RELATIVE TO CALIFORNIA
FISHING AND BOATING WEEK.
CINNABAR THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER PRESIDENT I'M PLEASED TO
RISE TODAY TO PRESENT ACR ANYONE
BY SOME MEMBER GIPSON APPRECIATE
ALL HIS HARD WORK.
IT'S GOING TO DECLARE THE WEEK
OF JUNE FIRST GUIDE THROUGH THE
NINETEENTH IS CALIFORNIA FODIO
FISHING AND BOATING WEEKS
RECREATIONAL BOATING IS VITAL
THE CALIFORNIA ECONOMY AT THE
ANNUAL IMPACT OF THIRTEEN
BILLION DOLLARS ALONG WITH.
FORTY ONE THOUSAND JOBS
SPORTFISHING MISTER PRESIDENT
IT'S ALSO VITAL TO TOURISM
ECONOMY HERE IN CALIFORNIA WITH
OVER TWO MILLION ANGLER SPENDING
TWO POINT NINE BILLION DOLLARS
FOR FISHING.
ANGLER AND ANGLERS AND VOTERS
ARE STEWARDS OF THE ENVIRONMENT
CONTRIBUTED ONE POINT SIX
BILLION IN EXCISE TAXES ANNUALLY
TO THE FEDERAL SPORT FISH
RESTORATION AND BUILDING TRUST.
ONE THIS RESOLUTION RECOGNIZES
THE BENEFITS THE CITY CALIFORNIA
GAINS FROM ARE THRIVING
RECREATIONAL FISHING
RECREATIONAL BOATING INDUSTRY IN
ADDITION A FLOWERS AS WELL WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OF BET ON
THIS ITEM.
SEEN SEEN NINE MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN.
HI ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS AYE BATES.
AYE BILL.
BY PORGES.
HI BRADFORD.
I COME A YELLOW.
I CHIANG.
BY DODD [inaudible]
HI RUSSEL [inaudible]
I GALGIANI.
HI GLAZER BY GROWTH [inaudible]
I HERTZBERG.
I HILL.
AYE HUESO -- TADO.
BY JACKSON.
I JONES.
BY LEYVA.
I'M ACQUIRE BY MITCHELL
[inaudible]
BY MONNING.
I'M MORE LUCK I'M REAL.
I NIELSEN.
BY PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO.
I ROTH.
I RUBIO [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
BY STERN [inaudible]
BY STONE.
NUMBER.
HI MY COUNTY.
I WIENER.
HI WILK.
HI.
MR KERRY PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS HUESO [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
STONE.
CINNABAR MOVES A CALL
.
MEMBERS ARE GONNA LOOK TO CALL
ON ITEM.
TEN MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
OUT TO MEMBERS [inaudible]
GALGIANI [inaudible]
BY [inaudible]
WITH SO [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
STONE.
ICE THIRTY FIVE NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES NEXT MEMBERS WERE
GONNA LOOK TO CALL ON ITEM.
TWENTY ONE MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
HUESO [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
STONE.
ALL EYES THIRTY FIVE NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS ARE GOING TO RETURN BACK
TO MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS --
THIS IS A TIME FOR JOURNEY
MEMORIES WE HAVE ANY A GERMAN
MEMBERS.
CENTER I'M BURGER YOU PREPARE UP
UNDER UNDER MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS
MISTER PRESIDENT YES UNDER
MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS THIS PRESENT
PLEASE MOVE AB. SEVENTEEN FIFTY
TWO AND A. B. EIGHTEEN TWENTY
NINE TO THE INACTIVE FILE AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR THANK YOU.
NOTED THANK YOU [inaudible]
ANY ADDITIONAL.
MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS SENIOR NINE
WHEN I THOUGHT WE HAD A JOURNEY
MEMORY NO [inaudible]
YES.
SENATOR UMBERG USES YOUR DURING
A MEMORY IT IS MY JOURNAL MEMORY
WHEN YOU'RE READY FOR ME THANK
YOU MISTER PRESIDENT MEMBERS.
OF TODAY ASKED THAT WE ADJOURN
IN MEMORY OF DAVID HOUSTON LEE --
MISTER LEE WAS BORN ON MAY SIXTH
NINETEEN TWENTY FIVE IN MUSKOGEE
OKLAHOMA HE SERVED OUR NATION.
FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS INCLUDING
MANY YEARS DURING WORLD WAR --
TWO SADLY BUT MAYBE
APPROPRIATELY.
MR LEAVES NINETY FOUR YEARS OLD
AND DIED ON MEMORIAL DAY -- HE
AND HIS WIFE FORMED A LIFELONG
[inaudible]
PARTNERSHIP.
OF JOINED BY THEIR CHILDREN --
HE WOULD PLAY HIM HIS WIFE WOULD
SING ALONG IN THE VOCALS -- HE
WAS IT A SALES PERSON IN A
SIGNIFICANT CONTRIBUTOR TO OUR
COMMUNITY HE LEFT DISTINCT
IMPACT ON EACH AND EVERY
INDIVIDUAL ACROSS INCLUDING.
UPON ME COLLEAGUES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT WE RISE
AND DURING THE DAY IN MEMORY OF
DAVID CHIU ASSEMBLY THANK YOU.
WE HAVE THE SENATE WE'RE GONNA
EXTEND OUR DEEPEST CONDOLENCES
AND SENATE ON BOARD IF YOU BRING
THE NAME PORTS ARE TO BE
PROPERLY MORAL LIVES THANK YOU.
MEMBERS ANY ADDITIONAL ADJOURN
AND MEMORIES SEEN ON ANY.
ADDITIONAL ACTIVITY.
THAT BEING THE CASE IF THERE'S
NO FURTHER BUSINESS SENATOR
ATKINS THE DOSES COLOR.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT AND
YOU KNOW IN HONOR OF OUR
COLLEAGUES BIRTHDAY FROM NAPA
OUR CONFERENCE COMMITTEE WORKED
VERY HARD OVER THE WEEKEND.
WHILE HE WAS US CELEBRATING HIS
BIRTHDAY WE WERE MAKING SURE
THAT HE COULD ENJOY HIS BIRTHDAY --
I WANNA I DON'T THINK I SAY IT
ENOUGH AND I DON'T THINK WE CAN
SAY IT ENOUGH PARTICULARLY OUR
APPRECIATION TO OUR CONFERENCE
COMMITTEE CONFEREES -- YOUR
DILIGENT WORK HI.
HAS GOTTEN US TO A VERY GOOD
PLACE FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS.
I HAVEN'T SAID THAT WE WILL
RECONVENE ON THURSDAY RIGHT NOW
THE TIME IS SCHEDULED FOR NINE
AM -- I BELIEVE ARE.
BUDGET DOCUMENTS NGUYEN INTO
PRINT BUT THERE IS A TIME ISSUE
BUT I WILL LET YOU KNOW BUT BE
PREPARED TO BE HERE AT NINE AM
ON THURSDAY.
UNLESS YOU HEAR OTHERWISE MISTER
PRESIDENT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM PRO TEM.
THE SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS
UNTIL THREE THIRTY AT WHICH TIME
INTO IT.
BERMAN -- MOTION WILL BE.
I'M SORRY SENATOR DODD MY
APOLOGIES.
YES UNDER ANNOUNCEMENTS I'D LIKE
TO DOUBTS DISLIKE COMMITTEE ON
WILDFIRES A CLIMATE CHANGE WILL
MEET IMMEDIATELY UPON WELL
ACTUALLY OR BE AT THREE PM TODAY.
WILL BE MEETING AT THREE PM
TODAY IN ROOM.
ONE TWELVE DULY NOTED.
ANY FURTHER ANNOUNCEMENT
[inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
THE SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS
UNTIL THREE THIRTY AT WHICH TIME
IN A GERMAN MOTION WILL BE
PLACED WE WILL RECONVENE
THURSDAY MORNING AT NINE AM THIS
CONCLUDES OUR BUSINESS FOR THIS
AFTERNOON